oh my god we better save some those Oh
My gods for later during coitus of
course what are you doing here I would
like to throw my penis into the ring and
buy a ring I mean your innocence I would
be honored to make love tea tonight
Billy time due to do I would never ever
have sex with you okay but I would
rather die a virgin
rather tired Billy did you call Brett
yeah I know
not my first option but he's very
prepared he already has a condom on and
there's flyers yes okay but I kept it
very discreet I just put your first name
P on headphones buzzing I have 500 wings
from an elderly dating app called
penultimate I went ahead and signed you
up for that because of their old miss
the elderly tend to be sort of
slow-moving and tender lovers sort of
like doing it with a snail only it's hot
Jean do me a favor don't do me any
favors okay so do the favor don't do the
favor don't do the favor
Jean please stop tell her Nick Ellie why
wait before you go how are you wearing
dress hey your are these - tips really
good in my bed is that what you're gonna
say Bret no in the kitchen there be
crumbs all over the bed I'm not a crumb
monster can I just have some alone time
please okay fair enough but uh do you
need a shoulder to snack on in a dirty
way oh my god look I may need prosthetic
virgin but at least I'm not begging for
it okay
new case of a TV that's why you don't
see fun but they still wanna be